methodische kritik an drosten
kinderstudie kommt übrigens auch von
kollegen das gehört bei einer
vorabversion aber zum wissenschaftlichen
prozess
das weiß ich weil ich eine minute lang
gegoogelt habe aber so viel zeit hat die
bild natürlich nicht so und jetzt reden
wir endlich mal über markus söder hat
der einen lauf junge junge 48 prozent
für die csu in aktuellen umfragen 48 das
sind 11 mehr als bei der letzten bayern
war ein wahnsinn absoluter wahnsinn von
söders eigenen beliebtheitswerten mal
ganz zu schweigen
wie geht man damit um wenn ein plötzlich
alle lieben es scheint in den scheck zu
sein der ihre popularität steigert geht
das vorbei wie jeder infekt natürlich
geht es wieder vorbei sie ist auch für
die demokratie nicht gut wenn wert ist
so überragend sind wenn man so
überragend geil is weg das ist auf dauer
nicht gesund wirklich man kann auch zu
phantastisch sein
ja wenn das so weitergeht verlegte
seinen amtssitz bald nach neuschwanstein
letztes wochenende hatte die csu
übrigens ihren ersten digitalen
parteitag ganz tolle sache highlight für
mich neben der rede von söder natürlich
das frische freche moderatorin doppel
aus digitalen ministerin dorothee bär
und generalsekretär markus blume also
viel besser kann man es nicht machen
jedenfalls nicht mit den beiden wir
haben da drüben den roten knopf den wenn
man den drückt noch nicht machen
nachdem du das spiel bei der
generalprobe kaputt gemacht hat weiß ich
nicht ob ich jetzt dringend bitten nicht
alle geheimnisse der generalprobe dir zu
teilen wenn ich in die gesichter schaue
hat auch jeder dem leitantrag zugestimmt
herzlichen dank lieber markus für eine
richtungsweisende rede die du gerade zu
uns gesprochen hast die menschen in
unserem land vertrauen dir
das mit rechts ich begrüße ganz herzlich
unseren markus söder weissengruber
qantas war original applaus vom
csu-parteitag bei deiner wahl zum
parteivorsitzenden aha aha auch sei das
schon fertig mit schleim
schleimt ruhig weiter wir haben alle
zeit der welt blume und bär
da können marianne und michael aber
einpacken ich behaupte die beiden
brauchen dringend einen eigenen sender
geo tv
der neue csu digitalkanal mit
programmhighlights wie blume und bei der
show wo blume und wer einfach nur an der
kamera vorbei gucken und blinzeln direkt
danach hart aber wer unsere polit
magazin und mit dem thema die zehn
größten politiker aller zeiten von
emmvee markus bis es wieder verpassen
sie bloß unser neues quiz wer weiß denn
sowas kai pflaume stellt markus söder
fragen über markus söder und für unsere
kleinen eine neue folge von
meistersinger und sein csu mucke mit an
die schoah in der rolle des nervigen
verkehrs kobolds weiß-blau tv immer live
aus dem rektum von markus söder
[Musik]
herrlich ehrlich tatsache ist bayern und
die csu machen in der korona krise keine
schlechte figur
diese sehr ordentliche krisen management
muss man aber trennen von der sonstigen
csu performance woran der partei körper
zum beispiel nach wie vor krank ist
natürlich die sache mit der maut ja
gestern war wieder
untersuchungsausschuss in berlin
nach recherchen von report mainz hat
andy schoy us-verkehrsministerium den
bundesrechnungshof und den bundestag
wohl bewusst getäuscht
warum ist der immer noch im amt wie oft
habe ich das in dieser sendung schon
gefragt ich weiß es nicht
keiner aus der csu übernimmt
verantwortung für die über 500 millionen
die sie als steuerzahler bald für ihre
tracks mit blechen sollen wirklich wo
man hinguckt 0 schuldgefühl gekommen
weil ein gericht und hebt es auf das
krankenhaus geplant
alle haben geweint ja ich werde jede
stunde geräumt
von morgens bis abends werde ich gewarnt
es ist mir scheißegal
auch das kann den umfragewerten der csu
nichts anhaben ich frage mal die
parteien forscherin birte schneider
warum eigentlich nicht auch die mode
interessiert keinen hering wird alles
überschattet von ihm
mythos markus 120 kilo reinstes charisma
jeder auftritt perfekt
durchchoreografiert hier auf ihren jagd
an der bayerisch-österreichischen grenze
breitbeinig entschlossen aber
gleichzeitig irgendwie sensibel man
sieht dass und weiß einfach wenn dieser
mann will wo der nächstes jahr in berlin
die kanzlerschaft ist eine reife saftige
frucht die nur darauf wartet von ihnen
gepflückt zu werden die ihm zuruft
nämlich markus du willst es doch auch
mit ihm ist aber schon alles in ordnung
oder herr welke
man muss das einfach auch mal
handwerklich respektieren wenn ein
politiker sich so radikal neu erfindet
der söder spricht plötzlich mit so einer
sanften stimme und sagt sachen fixpunkt
mir das kleid habe
übrigens das heißt nicht dass ich alles
von uns durchsetzen muss es gibt gute
ideen bei der spd es gibt gute ideen bei
der cdu es gibt gute ideen aus dem
landtag heraus von grünen und anderen
söder lobt die grünen eine tüte edelweiß
geraucht oder was das ist so ein
radikaler image wechsel als würde keine
ahnung rammstein mit rolf zuckowski
kinderlieder singen oder bärte zum islam
konvertieren und ich glaube dem markus
ich glaube dem ich weiß selber nicht
warum
keine frage er ist ein guter
krisenmanager bmx aber einfach auch mal
zugeben wir uns einer drauf hat auch die
ganze social media sache der moderne
politiker ist maximal transparent lässt
den bürger immer teil haben hier söder
instagram posts nur aus den letzten
tagen einen guten schaschlik kann man
kaum widerstehen mittagessen wiener mit
scharfen senf wunderbar angerichtet
übrigens oder rollmops am morgen
schmeckt echt gut
erstens nein zweitens kann ich dem söder
ja seine neuen beliebtheitswerte klar
aber warum 48 prozent für die csu wegen
dieser regionalpartei platz unser
bundestag in berlin bald aus allen
nähten
kein witz wegen dem haben wir immer noch
kein neues wahlrecht und dass wir das
bisher nicht hinbekommen haben das ist
die schuld der großen koalition das ist
aber nicht die schuld der gesamten
großen koalition
der bösewicht ist die union und
innerhalb der union ist es nicht die
schuld der gesamten union der bösewicht
ist die csu und das muss man auch so
ganz klar sagen und ich sage jetzt mal
einen ungeheuerlichen satz hinterher
der fdp mann hat völlig recht ja es ist
tatsächlich die csu die sämtliche
reformvorschläge der anderen parteien
stumpf blockiert weil sie weiter ihre
direktmandate haben wollen sagte söder
nix zu gar nichts im worst case haben
wir bald über 800 abgeordnete kostet pro
legislaturperiode eine halbe milliarde
mehr und ganz normaler mautsatz jetzt
seien sie mal nicht so ein erbsenzähler
niemand mag geizhälse und ob uns das
gefällt oder nicht
ein kanzler söder halten solche fußnoten
nicht mehr auf ich kenne sogar schon das
plakat für seine kampagne markus söder
ob es am morgen schmeckt echt gut so was
wollen die leute hören ich bin raus
birte schneider
[Applaus]
alter der club hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn inhaltlich stark satire comedy
gruppe
ich habe es noch drauf also ich würde
den kanal direkt abonnieren und auf
gefällt mir drücken wenn ich das nicht
so getan hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]